When the World Cup comes around, there's
a lot of pressure on this guy, Harry
Kane, the England football captain.
But in addition to his day job, Kenny
also say that the league, its temple of
consumerism, the shopping.
It may seem an unlikely match up, but
he's involved in a big bet on future
shopping, of which more later.
Let's start with the basics.
The business model for shopping malls
used to be pretty straightforward.
You would offer cheap rent to a
department store like Nordstrom or
Macy's in the U.S.
or John Lewis and Debanhams.
In the UK.
And they would become what is known as
an anchor tenant.
The idea is that they would bring in
shoppers from miles around to then make
it easier to attract smaller shops to
fill the spots around it.
That would fill out your e-commerce.
Changed all that.
If you could buy something online that
would appear on your doorstep a day or
two later, it was suddenly less
appealing to drive Miles to an out
town shopping center and department
stores in particular suffered.
Many of them closed down.
That creates a problem for landlords who
all of a sudden didn't have an anchor
tenant, which is where Harry Kane comes
in.
He's an investor in TOCA.
Social is part of a new wave of
businesses that are booming as we emerge
from the Covid-19 pandemic.
I like to come and maybe go newer
companies who maybe have a bigger growth
and bigger chance to expand then known
as experiential entertainment or
entertainment.
Sometimes bars that incorporate another
activity, such as mini golf in the case
of Puttshack, darts in the case of flight
club table tennis.
When it comes to bounce and football,
soccer in the case of take out social.
So experiential entertainment economy
has exploded in recent years and this is
a trend we expect to accelerate.
We're seeing a kind of a market increase
in people wanting to do more than nights
out beyond just eating and drinking.
And many people well, many companies
have already applied to experiential
entertainment model very successfully at
different sports, most notably golf, but
also darts and and others.
Players get a little booth where they
aim to hit moving targets on the screen.
With a football, you can have a beer and
some chicken wings while your mates are
playing.
This isn't the bowling alley of your
grandparents.
There's all sorts of technical wizardry.
The good news for shopping malls and
their landlords is that these sort of
spots attract families and kids during
the day and the social crowd out for a
drink in the evening.
Department stores are always seen as as
the anchors of the shopping centers.
I think to be to be frank, they haven't
anchored them in the way they were
originally intended for quite a while.
These are not new spaces by now.
I think there are some new concepts and
there are new ways to be managed.
The key thing is, is that it now has a
wider reach.
I think he's got a broader demographic
you think is better engage with the
local customer in many cases locations
that used to be occupied by department
stores and now being offered to these
experiential entertainment firms.
That also means they're getting some of
the same deals on the rent.
In the case of Pop Shack, the setup
costs are about 8 million dollars and in
many cases landlords are fronting as
much as two thirds of that to entice
them in.
It appears to pay off.
Consumers played a million games of mini
golf in Park Shaq's first year at its
location in West London, and they take
up a pretty big footprint to 30 to 40
thousand square feet, not quite as big
as the 70000 square feet of a department
store, but still bigger than a lot of
other shops.
Many of these concepts are originating
in the UK before they cross the pond to
the US.
Puttshack, which just raised 150
million dollars from BlackRock, was
founded by Stephen and Dave Jolliffe,
the same brothers who sold top golf to
Callaway for two billion dollars just a
few years ago.
The firm behind Bounce and Flight Club
is based in London and just raised an
additional 35 million dollars in
funding.
Harry Kane invested in Tokyo Social in
January.
He's hoping that the business helps pay
some of the bills when he ultimately
gets around to retiring.
The company aims to add as many as 50
sites in the UK and expand globally.
I fear that this will grow as the years
go on and there will be tweets made
along the way that improve it.
And maybe by the time I'm retired, I'll
be in a really fantastic place and I
could just maybe enjoy playing football
for fun instead of professionally.
Harry Kane can't save the shop more on
his own, nor can toke a social.
But landlords certainly hope that these
sort of spots can give them a new lease
of life.